Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
in surah m
chapter number 73
vers
verses number 11 or verses 11
through 14
verses 11-4.
In these verses, Allah Subhanahu Wa
Ta'ala speaks about
and informs the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam
of the consequences of disbelief.
What is it that awaits
a person who rejects the message of
Allah
on the other side of the life of this
world? Once a person crosses that
threshold,
that threshold of death and transitions
from this life into the hereafter, which
is the real life,
this here is
you could look at this life as
being very vague.
It is not vivid and it is not the real
reality in which we were created for.
This life has been constructed as a
test.
And when a person transitions from this
life to the next, immediately
everything becomes crystal clear.
Everything becomes so clear
that they cannot even fathom
how a person could not have seen the
truths that the messengers have informed
of.
Imagine any disbeliever throughout
history. Imagine the most staunch
of antagonists of the prophets and
messengers. Imagine their arguments
and their debates and their confusion
and their doubts and so on and so forth.
But once they arrive on the other side,
once they arrive and awaken in the real
and permanent place and life,
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us that
they will say
The messengers of our Lord did in fact
bring the truth. It's exactly as they
said.
And how could it even be considered to
be any other way?
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us about
this critical moment that when a person
passes away
as soon as they find themselves on the
other side of death
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
that when the person is on the other
side. Allah says
we have removed the veil from their eyes
at this moment and now they see things
as we would say 2020
2020.
It all makes sense. It all fits
together. But at that moment that
understanding and that wisdom that a
person gains is of little consequence
because for the believers it will only
increase their
joy and for the disbeliever it will only
increase their misery.
And so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala in
these verses
he tells us what awaits
those who reject the messages of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
And this also includes
those who just don't care enough to
look.
Often times we imagine that the only
person that is held to account is a
person who is presented with the truth
and it is made 100% clear to them and
then they reject it outwardly.
That's not the case.
A person who just squanders his life. A
person who just doesn't bother to look
for the truth. A person who just doesn't
take it upon himself to give that any
merit and that research and that and
to discover what they were created for
and who is their creator and why they
exist. This is a type of kufur that is
addressed in the Quran. It's called
the disbelief of
of just turning away. It's just not
it's minute. It's not a big deal. They
just don't care. That is a type of
disbelief.
and in the time of the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam, people this
existed.
As a matter of fact, a group of people
said to the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam, a man said to him,
[Silence]
He said, "If you really are a messenger
from Allah, then you are way too grand
and you have far too much gravitas for
me to follow you.
And if you are not, then you are too low
in my eye for me to give you the time of
day. So he's saying, if you really are a
messenger and this really is all true,
that's not my cup of tea.
That's just not my thing. I don't take
things so seriously, but I wish you the
best. Right?
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us and
and don't it's easy for us to kind of
sit back and say
well you know people are busy they're
busy with their jobs and work and bills
and you know Tik Tok and Facebook and
they're busy with YouTube and they're
busy you know trying to pay their
bills and plan their vacations and going
on cruises and stuff. It just doesn't
occur to people
to look for the truth. Is that true? Is
there any man amongst us here today,
young or old, except for little little
kids, who has not been on the brink of
death, the threshold of death, or had
moments where you were so afraid
that you felt there was nothing more
important in the world than being guided
and finding out who your creator is so
that you could beg him to relieve
whatever it is you're going through. Is
there a man amongst us who hasn't had a
tragedy in his life, a crisis,
a falling apart, a an epiphany,
an epiphous moment where you felt like
nothing mattered but knowing the truth.
There's not one human being on this
earth who doesn't have that. And you
don't get it once or twice. Just like
the people of Fyon, how many plagues
were sent upon Fyon? How many how many
signs and miracles were they given? And
how many warnings? Who knows?
Seven. Wrong.
Nine.
Over years and years. And that was not
just that was every people. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us that
anytime he sends a messenger to a people
when they first reject him, Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala then sends upon them
plagues and crises and calamities in
order to humble and and humble their
hearts
and help them to find humility and bring
them to the edge of despair and the cusp
of despair so that they raise their
hands to the heavens
and then if they still reject after that
now they are in a different place now
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala replaces all
that hardship with ease and comfort and
they start to say see it's not about God
or good or bad right every people they
have good times and they have bad times
Right? What's important is family.
What's important is our career. What's
important is the military. What's
important is my money. What's important
is right. And there's nothing unique
about that. This wasn't from, you know,
a creator who is sending a messenger to
us and so on and so forth. No, this is
just this is just the nature of life.
Everyone has good times. Everyone has
bad times. There's nothing special,
unique or tailor fitted about it. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala then says
and once they reach that position, he
takes them immediately and permanently.
Subhanahu wa ta'ala.
So don't think that you know the person
you see in the street and they look
happy and they look contented that they
don't have those moments between
themselves and Allah. They do. It's just
that every time they reject it and every
time they put their head in the sand and
every time they don't care, they get
further and further away from the truth
to the point that when the truth really
is presented to them, they are so lost
that they don't even understand most of
what is being said to them.
And the idea that people are just not
here, people are not in the masid,
people are not believers, people are not
Muslim because they just don't know.
Today in this day and age, they don't
know. Nobody knows. Nobody's heard of
Islam.
They've not been curious enough just to
say, "You know what? Let me just for the
heck of it read a Wikipedia article."
Never. never once.
And this is why things war and and
so forth take place. Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala allows these wars to happen
because what happens to Islam when a
Muslim country is invaded or attacked or
what have you. Islam now spreads
everywhere and it becomes the talking
point and everyone becomes familiar with
it.
How did you all reach here tonight?
Aren't you busy? Don't you have places
to be and things to do? And but you
chose to look for guidance and you
fought your way here.
And if you chose not to do that, that
doesn't make you off the hook. Our
messenger didn't come for no good
reason.
This is not an optional situation where
you know if you want to go ahead and
believe if you don't want to then you
know life's busy and right that's not
what we were created for and every one
of us knows that there is a reason
behind our creation but we get
distracted
and that distraction
were it not for the blessing and mercy
of Allah would continue until we died.
But Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala refuses to
allow us to be distracted all the time.
We are hit with problems and calamities
and difficulties because it wakes us up.
It gives us a moment of clarity in which
we are to search. And you know there are
many arguments one of the arguments
is
well there are thousands of religions in
the earth. Am I expected to research
every single one of those religions to
find the truth? You guys have heard this
before. This is one of the most silly
purile arguments ever. Why? If I said to
you right now,
I lost my keys, my car keys.
I can't find them. Could you help me
find my keys? And you said to me, 'Well,
there are literally thousands of places
in this house where those keys could be.
Do you expect me to look in every single
square inch of the house?
Would you start in the refrigerator
looking for the keys? Huh?
What about what about x-raying the cat
to see if the the cat swallowed the keys
or the dog ate them? Would you start
there? Is that where you would start?
Would you start by taking the soles off
your shoes to make sure the keys didn't
get in there somehow?
How silly is that? You begin searching
in the most reasonable places where
those keys would be. Yes, there are
thousands of so-called religions on the
earth today. But are there not religions
that billions of people follow right now
on the earth? Yes. Wouldn't you start
there? or would you start with some
obscure weird religion and some
aboriginal you know new of the of the
of the Amazon or something that.
Why would you start there? You would
begin with what most people probably
are on to something and you would look
through those religions.
You have Christianity, Judaism, Islam,
billions of followers for Christianity,
billions of followers for Islam. If you
were to make that comparison alone and
read only a a few verses of the Quran,
immediately it becomes clear, no
competition.
There is no competition. And there is no
way to just dismiss the Quran as some
kind of novel or some kind of ramblings
of a madman. It's just not possible.
The truth is clear. It is clear. But if
a person chooses to allow himself to be
distracted and drunk enough and party
and ignore until he runs out of time.
That was his choice. Correct.
The prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam tells us in Muslim he says
he said Allah has left no excuse
for any man or woman who has arrived at
the age of 60 years old and has not
managed to become guided.
If you live to 60 years old, you have
zero
excuses.
No more excuses for why you don't know
what's expected of you as a Muslim. No
more excuses as a non-Muslim, to not
have searched and looked for the truth.
And every one of us feels in our heart
of hearts, even little kids, those of us
who have children here, when your child
first starts speaking, what are the
questions that they ask? Where did we
come from? Where is Allah?
Where why do we exist? Why do I exist?
That's a small child. Why is the adult
not asking those questions? Because he's
entertained and because he is he is
sidetracked. That is the only reason.
His eyes and ears are filled with noise.
The noise of the dunya. That's the only
thing that stops those questions. And
where does Islam, specifically Islam and
generally religion and spirituality,
where is it? Where does it grow the
fastest and the most amongst people? And
which
part of society?
Huh?
No, not poor people. Where?
Where? Huh? the west prison. Why prison?
Why?
[Arabic recitation]
That's all.
That's all
because you are forced to sit there and
think just for a minute. And Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala he says
to say to the prophet, he tells the
prophet sallall.aii Wasam
is
he said, "I just have one challenge for
you. Just one.
stand in pairs
or alone and just think about it.
That's it. That was the challenge that
Allah placed. Just get away from the
pack.
Get away from the pack mentality for a
minute.
If you'd choose an intelligent
friend with you
or on your own and just think about what
Muhammad has said. Sallallah.aii
wasallam. That is it.
And this book is potent enough that
anyone who takes that challenge
seriously will become Muslim or will
reject it knowingly will reject it
knowing that it is the truth. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us what he's
prepared for the disbelievers on the
other side. He says
he says indeed we have and we here is
the royal we. Allah is speaking about
himself
with in the plural using a plural
pronoun. And this is referred to in
English as the royal we. In Arabic they
say
subh
or he is saying we meaning he and his
angels. Subhanahu wa ta'ala because in
some places in the Quran when Allah
refers to himself as we he's speaking
about himself alone but he's using we as
a form of exaltation of himself and in
other instances he is using we and it
means the angels
for instance
[Silence]
So he says indeed we do have with us
and here is for nickel.
[Silence]
He says, "We have for them prepared
restraints
and
a
hell existence, a hellacious existence.
Alahim here is referring to the
hellfire.
But the word
articulates intensity and it is referred
to asim because of the intensity of its
fire.
The Arabs they say
meaning a a person who is in war you
can see the fury in his eyes.
So Elahim is a furious fire. That is
what Elahim means. So he says we have
with us for them
restraints,
chains and yolks and a furious raging
fire.
And we have
food
for them that they will take and ingest
into the insides of their bodies.
That is very unwelcome to the body.
for
[Silence]
the
So he says and food for them that they
will ingest that will stick in their
throat and they will find it very
difficult to swallow just they
found the truth very difficult difficult
to swallow. Just their pride and
their arrogance was too much for them to
swallow, to bow their knees and their
faces to Allah, their creator. Likewise,
their nutrition, their food, all those
years in the dunya, drinking and eating
and singing and doing whatever they
want. Now
they will have to fight and struggle to
drink or or ingest anything because it
is exactly the opposite of paradise.
What is the name of the river in
paradise? We hear it every morning on
Jum. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says that
it has the essence of ginger in it.
What is the name of that river?
listen to the to the description of
it's using the letter scene. And by the
way, you notice how scene is written,
right? These letters take their shapes
from Aramaic originally.
and seen was used
as a letter that would describe
water. It wasn't a letter before. It was
a it was a what do they call those? U
huh
pictogram
you know the Rosetta stone what
what are they called? Hieroglyphics.
Thank you sir. We have the educated
amongst us here. Hieroglyphics.
So it was a hieroglyph that was used in
ancient Aramaic way before they started
to use these hieroglyphs and take these
symbols and put them and make letters
out of them. If you could imagine for
instance the symbols that we use like
in an airport you have the the man for
the male restroom and you have the
female for the female restroom. You have
an airplane as a symbol for where the
plane is, right? That's what these
Arabic letters used to be. They
originally were drawings that held a
meaning. A scene
was used as a hieroglyph
to articulate water
because if you look at it, it looks like
looks little ripples in the water.
Right? Now that scene has that meaning
in the Quran in in the Arabic language
when we use the letter scene, right? It
articulates smooth something that is
smooth and flowing.
The name of the river is Sabil.
for
[Silence]
right
there
Right? So when you have repetition of
letters or repetition of a series of
letters in a word in Arabic in the Quran
this articulates movement and rhythm.
So scene is repeated here in this word
due to the smoothness of its flow. And
when they drink it, it smoothly flows
down their very smoothly on its own.
They don't need the muscles to take it
down and gravity to take it down. It
wants to be inside of their body, inside
of their bellies. Contrary and the stark
opposite to what
the
for
subhanahu
Subhanahu
[Silence]
Wasam.
You started this right when we started,
right? So we went 25 minutes, 28
minutes
[Arabic recitation]
half an hour. So I started a little bit.
I stopped a little bit early, right?
[Silence]
Just